bueno
[Música]
por qué
y
tenía 18 años cuando una compañera me
convenció para empezar pintura con la
profesora marta suchet y yo dibujaba
desde muy chico pero solo por hobby
recuerdo que lo primero que me hizo
pintar fue lo que se denomina la
naturaleza muerta para lo que no conocen
era un jarrón con un par de frutas y
otros elementos arriba una mesa era una
prueba para evaluar mi capacidad después
de varios trabajos prácticos me dijo que
ya podía comenzar mi primera pintura
también me aclaro que a todos sus
alumnos la primera obra sólo se la
dejaba hacer con lápices de pastel pero
que a mí me permitiría la técnica que
quisiera yo en ese momento era fanático
de los redonditos de ricota y me parece
una buena idea como mi primera pintura
no tenía manejo del óleo ni de trabajar
con pinceles pero igual me compré un
lienzo de 80 x un metro y comencé
terminarlo me llevo aproximadamente unos
seis meses a los pocos días de
finalizarlo se realizó una muestra el
rosario donde puse junto a mis
compañeros
antes de viajar a marte me comentó que
en toda muestra siempre hay una hora que
llama la atención del espectador es
recuerdo ver como la gente se
concentraba alrededor de mi pintura en
ese momento un grupo de personas me
llamó para hacerme un par de preguntas
cuántos años hace qué pintas que número
de obra es cuando yo les digo que solo
recién comenzaba y que se trataba de mi
primera pintura pude ver caras de
asombro seguidos de halagos esa
experiencia me dio empuje para seguir
pintando
al año siguiente comencé la carrera de
diseño gráfico en rosário mientras
cursaba los fines de semana trabajaba
como diseñador en el alargue un
periódico deportivo de la ciudad
en ese momento les propuse a los dueños
dibujar a los jugadores en caricaturas
les encantó la idea y así fue que todas
las semanas se publicaban los dibujos en
la contratapa el diario
después varios meses recibí un llamado
de fernando vergara un profe de fútbol
que en ese momento trabajaba en los
molinos y me comentó que tenía de hobby
escribir cuentos de fútbol y si me
interesaba ilustrar esos cuentos me
aclaro acá no hay un mango es sólo por
pasión
ya llevamos 14 años como amigos
publicamos dos libros de cuentos de
fútbol y este año estamos por publicar
el tercero que se llamará la cilia
además en el 2018 inauguramos nuestra
página web llamada por el chori la coca
hasta hace tres años atrás
estaba acostumbrado a dibujar o pintar
en el escritorio de casa la verdad una
forma bastante solitaria y de la cual ya
no estaba disfrutando tanto pero un día
al ver una artista pintando un mural en
la ciudad me despertó la curiosidad y
las ganas es lo mismo
así fue que un domingo soleado realicé
mi primer mural en el patio de casa
para el segundo tuve que esperar un
miércoles feriado
elegí una pared de un álbum que da una
placita a la vuelta de casa la elección
del lugar fue por dos motivos el primero
porque me quedaba muy cerca
y el segundo porque era una placita por
la que no pasaba mucha gente y si me
quedaba mal no se vería a medida que iba
pintando comenzó lo interesante de
chicos que pasan en bici se acercaron a
mirar vecinos que en momentos teníamos
una relación de hola y chau me empezaron
a contar historias y vivencias muchos
compartían la misma pasión que la mía
pero que la vida los había llevado a
trabajar de otra cosa esa fue mi primera
experiencia con las personas me pareció
maravilloso
no todos conocían a nelson mandela pero
si compartían su idea
con este mural conseguido récord el
primero terminarlo en solo tres días y
el segundo este lo analizaron un día
después de finalizarlo la noticia así
sobria lo tácticamente y con esto
descubrí que las personas que me
felicitaban y compartían mi obra en las
redes sociales ahora me daban palabras
de aliento y fuerzas para para que siga
pintando
esto me recordó una frase de facundo
cabral que dice
que el bien es mayoría pero no se nota
porque es silencioso y una bomba hace
más ruido que una caricia pero por cada
bomba que destruye hay millones de
caricias que construyen la vida
si mandela pudo soportar 27 años preso
luego salir ser presidente y acabar con
la desigualdad racial como llegó a bajar
los brazos la verdad que la verdad que
nunca me lo tomé como algo personal
sabía que pintar en la calle podría
tener esta consecuencia nunca imaginé
que podía pasar tan rápido
hace un tiempo venía con la idea de
pintar a la madre teresa de calcuta
ya tenía el boceto pero me faltaba el
lugar cuando ocurre una casualidad
era un día semana afuera un calor que no
se soportaba yo estaba esperando que un
amigo abriera su negocio como faltaba un
ratito y aproveché para irme a tomar un
helado
en eso entran las maestras y los chicos
de una escuela católica de pujato mi
novia que formaba parte de las maestras
me presentó la directora y en los 15
minutos que hablamos le muestro el
boceto y a la semana siguiente ya estaba
pintando en el colegio
de estar en el patio mi casa a pintar en
otra localidad me generaba nuevas
sensaciones estaba inquieto contento
ansioso por por no saber qué persona iba
a conocer cómo me iban a recibir y si
realmente podía cubrir la expectativa de
ellos
una vez más me encontré con gente
maravillosa tanto los grandes como los
chicos me acompañaron en todo momento y
hasta me invitaron al almuerzo de fin de
año desde el colegio
pero de todas las personas que pasaban
por el lugar
me sorprendió un caso en particular
un hombre frenó con su auto y desde
arriba muy emocionado me dio las gracias
por la obra me dijo solo falta que hable
cuando se retiró me contaron que había
sido uno de los fundadores del colegio
ese fue el momento exacto que comprendí
por qué pinto
comprendí que como artista es mi deber
conectar con las personas tratar de
emocionar sorprender o inspirar
hoy el lugar tiene luces bancos flores
y el busto del fundador del colegio
y el mural de la madre teresa bendecido
por el obispo
poder ver como a una simple acción se le
suman otras acciones para mejorar un
lugar es increíble
hoy estamos acostumbrados a escuchar
palabras como crisis corrupción
violencia
los medios de comunicación nos muestran
todos los días la parte mala del mundo
por eso intento con cada moral dejar
mensajes positivos que no unan un poco
más como sociedad
generalmente pinto personas que inspiran
y tal vez puede inspirar o cambiar algo
en el otro
estoy convencido y para cambiar el mundo
no se requiere de super talentos sino de
pequeñas acciones diarias como decir
buen día buenas tardes o ayudar al que
tenemos al lado
además tener un talento requiere una
gran responsabilidad y si ese talento no
es usado para el bien de la sociedad no
tiene sentido
y recuerden que la vida como los murales
son efímeros pero lo que hagamos con el
corazón vivirá para siempre muchas
gracias
[Música]
no
y